bonjour à tous bienvenue c'est l'ère de
parlement hebdo 45 minutes pour faire le
trou de l'actualité politique
parlementaire avec catherine dallaire
bonjour ktr bonjour michael actualité
encore une fois très chargée avec le
bilan du deuxième tour des élections
départementales large victoire de la
droite ump udi le ps et la gauche
subissent une 8e défaite le fn
s'implante cholet territoire mais ne
gagne pas de département un an un manuel
valls fête son premier anniversaire à
matignon drôle de journée pour le
premier ministre cette semaine qui a
tenté de contenir la grogne des
socialistes tout en donnant des gages
aux écologistes et en répondant aux
attaques de la droite enfin le sénat a
rouvert le débat sur la lutte contre la
prostitution le texte voté au sénat est
à l'opposé de celui voté à l'assemblée
en 2013 principal changement le client
ne sera plus pénalisées et cette semaine
nous nous accueillons françois lamy
bonjour je vous remercie d'être sur le
plateau de parlement hebdo vous êtes
député socialiste de la 6ème
circonscription de l'essonne dont on a
parlé cette semaine ancien ministre de
la ville proche de martine aubry
beaucoup d'actualité pour vous mais je
vous propose d'abord d'écouter ce que
disent de vous certains de vos collègues
au vcro d'aurélia idéal écoutez je pense
qu'il a visiblement beaucoup de mal à
s'émanciper
de martine aubry on peut lui reconnaître
le mérite de la finalité mais je trouve
qu'ils s'enferment effectivement dans un
rôle d'apparatchiks de porte-flingue
d'hommes
parfois des mauvais coups porte-flingues
ne me paraît pas un mot très sympathique
et en tout cas moi qui étais au
gouvernement avec françois lamy je ne
les jamais
se méfier des démons sur les annonces et
autres françois lamy était l'ami de
martine aubry je crois surtout qu' il
allait une passionnante au maire de
lille donc c'est pas le travail de porte
flingue
le motet martine aubry à qui on colle à
la peau oui mais ça c'est assez c'est
assez logique puisque c'est vrai que
c'est une très grande proximité
politique avec elle que je travaille
avec elle depuis depuis 15 ans donc moi
je revendique cette proximité après le
mot de porte-flingue il est un peu
c'est une image de la politique qu'on
essaie de
donner non moi j'essaie surtout à la fin
j'ai la même conception qu'elle delà de
la politique à la fois pas forcément
théorique mais très pratique très très
concrète et puis assis sur des valeurs
et des convictions on est capable de
bouger en fonction de deux de
l'environnement et de la société dans
lequel on vit à quoi bon mais on reste
encore ancré l'un et l'autre sur son dos
valeur moment beaucoup en parler martine
aubry ont fait les g aussi on opposait
peut-être avec manuel va sûrement parler
pendant notre émission on commence avec
le bilan du deuxième tour des élections
départementales eros nous sommes lundi
alors la carte de france elle est assez
simple ça passe du rose au bleu en tout
cas majoritairement voici la nouvelle
couleur de la carte des départements
bouassa bilan de ce deuxième tour avec
françois goulard
ces élections sont une défaite cuisante
pour le gouvernement défaite politique
et personnel pour françois hollande et
manuel valls leurs fiefs respectifs
la corrèze et l'essonne bascule à droite
au total 25 départements change de mains
très rapidement le premier ministre a
reconnu un échec incontestable la gauche
trop dispersée trop divisée au premier
tour connaît un net recul malgré les
bons bilans des exécutifs départementaux
les appels à la mobilisation
républicaine ont été entendus mais les
scores très élevés beaucoup trop élevé
de l'extrême droite reste plus que
jamais un défi pour tous les
républicains
le fn peut en effet revendiquer un score
historique aux élections locales passant
d'un seul conseiller départemental à 62
aujourd'hui mais sont pour autant
reporter deux départements je suis
désormais à la tête du seul mouvement
d'opposition véritable pouvoir en place
libre et indépendant le front national
s'oppose à l'ump est ce dont chacun a pu
voir avec ces élections qu'elle est une
réalité indiscutable
le grand gagnant de ce scrutin et donc
la droite qui détient désormais deux
départements sur trois et remportent des
bastions historiques du ps comme les
côtes d'armor où les bouches du rhône à
gauche depuis plus de 60 ans pour
nicolas sarkozy ce résultat montre le
rejet des français pour le gouvernement
en place jamais un pouvoir en place
n'avait suscité une telle défiance et un
tel rejet au fond
jamais une politique n'avait autant
incarné l'échec à tous les niveaux je le
redis ce soir
l'alternance est en marche
rien ne l'arrêtera après cette déroute
départemental le parti socialiste va
devoir faire son autocritique et se
rassembler car se profile déjà les
régionales en décembre prochain le
dernier test électoral avant les
élections présidentielles de 2017 alors
pour analyser un petit peu ce scrutin
certains disent manque d'union à gauche
disent votre sanction mais le constat
que l'on fait c'est qu'il ya pas
forcément une envie de plus de gauche
après sélection départementale est là il
ya toujours plusieurs facteurs dans une
dans une victoire comme dans une défaite
d'ailleurs voilà c'est vrai qu'il ya eu
de la division à gauche mais pas tout le
temps c'est d'abord ça n'explique pas
tout parce que là où il n'y a pas eu
division à gauche dans un département
que ce que les miens que celui de
l'essonne il ya eu accord à gauche donc
a eu un bon premier tour mais un mauvais
deuxième tour donc ça n'a pas ça n'a pas
suffi ces divisions à gauche à la halle
à des causes il faut qu'on travaille sur
ses causes s'il ya des électeurs qui ne
se reconnaissent pas qui ne sont pas les
électeurs socialistes ils ne se
reconnaissent pas dans les candidats
socialistes voire même quand il était
allié avec avec des candidats verts
c'est qu'il ya un problème politique et
donc il faut qu'on soit
le parti socialiste arrive plus à
mobiliser à ses électeurs vous savez que
pour les compères will fall parti
socialiste il est quelque part l'image
de la politique de la gauche en général
et tout particulièrement aussi de la
politique gouvernementale
il a eu un dénia blement une volonté de
sanction de la politique du gouvernement
là encore qui est des fois juste des
fois injustes rebonds mais qui est réel
cette coupe il ya des endroits où
effectivement peut-être il ya eu un peu
un peu d'usure mais je crois que c'est
pas c'est pas suffisant il ya une
profonde de détresse d'une partie des
classes populaires il ya savez il se
rappelle quand même que le slogan de la
campagne présidentielle c'était le
changement c'est maintenant et comme il
n'a pas de place depuis trois ans de
résultats tangibles
par rapport à la crise qu'ils vivent
selon donc quand même responsable de cet
échec mais on est tous responsables
si vous avez le programme de la gauche
c'était le changement c'est maintenant
vous dit il n'y a pas eu de changement
le changement l'accusé incarné par
françois leroy pourquoi il n'y a pas eu
ce changement parce que d'une part
effectivement on a certainement
sous-estimé la gravité de la situation
qu'elle se trouvait à la fois développer
constant des finances publiques donc
fait ça a été moins compliqué on a assez
peu mesure est peut-être là la faiblesse
de notre appareil productif des
entreprises de ce pays grâce aux
effectifs qui n'était pas encore levé et
est bien sûr françois hollande vous
l'avez compris oui mais j'ai bien joué
mais lui aussi bien entendu il je pense
que s'il quand il s'escrime à il le dira
certainement il a forcément aussi sa
part de responsabilité comme comme moi
même qui était ministre du gouvernement
nous remarquons quand même pour 2017
pardon est il candidat naturel du
glacier nos ministes bien sûr que
françois hollande est le candidat
naturel de la gauche pour 2010 est
d'abord parce que ces cinq ans il nous
reste encore deux devant nous et moi je
ne suis pas de ceux qui pensent que ce
quinquennat est perdu bien au contraire
il y avait fait de grandes réformes il
peut encore s'en faire d'ici à d'ici là
et puis surtout on peut avoir des
résultats sur le principal terrain sur
lesquels les français nous attendent à
savoir le terrain économique et social
du tout particulièrement son front n'ont
pas si on parle de primaires à gauche ça
y est pour vous moi je pense que la
primaire c'est une primaire c'est un
élément dynamique pour pouvoir vous
pouvoir gagner quand même temps nous
avons le président sortant et il a des
responsabilités qui ne sont pas celles
d'un candidat de l'opposition il va
falloir qu'il gère à la fois le pays
mais aussi le la situation
internationale où les crises sont
peuvent être très très positif mais est
donc pas je considère pas que ce soit
très très utile de mettre en situation
de faiblesse et de fragilité le
président de la république pas trainer
moi je suis a priori non je ne suis pas
pour qu'il y ait une primaire à gauche
surtout que c'est le prix mais elle
n'est utile que c'est ce qu'on a fait la
dernière fois d'ailleurs que lorsqu'elle
permet le rassemblement c'est plutôt
l'impression que s'il y avait une
primaire fin fin 2016 il comprit étendu
à toute la gauche elle se déroulerait
pas forcément dans les mêmes conditions
alors on va passer à part d'ibm message
bien compris puisque cela fait un an
déjà un an que manuel valls est à
matignon
le premier ministre était omniprésent à
l'assemblée le matin devant le groupe
socialiste pour encourager ses troupes
puis dans l'hémicycle lors des questions
d'actualité où il a pris le micro à
plusieurs reprises
pour fêter sa première année à la tête
du gouvernement manuel valls est offert
une journée chargée interview matinale
post défaite électorale et pour lui
souhaiter un bon anniversaire on lui
demande s'il ne devrait pas quitter
matignon parce que les français
attendaient et me demandent ils me
demandent de rester au poste de les
écouter et continuer l'action pour
l'emploi par les emplois pour se
projeter plutôt que de ressasser la
défaite de dimanche mais manuel valls a
aussi une majorité à gérer direction le
groupe socialiste à l'assemblée pour
éviter que les frondeurs ne prennent
trop d'importance avec un mot clé
relayée par claude bartolone il y à une
nécessité je me répète d'un
rassemblement des socialistes et pour
rassembler quoi de mieux que de
s'adresser aux autres forces de gauche
dont les écologistes pour tenter de les
rallier à la cause gouvernementale ce
fut le cas aux questions d'actualité la
place des écologistes elle est dans la
majorité et j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de
le dire elle est pleinement au
gouvernement c'était le cas il ya un an
et pourquoi pas en profiter pour tacler
la droite qui elle aussi se pose la
question de son maintien à la tête du
gouvernement le résultat de dimanche
monsieur le premier ministre c'est votre
échec c'est vous qui avait hystériser la
campagne je vais vous rassurer je reste
et j'assume pleinement mes
responsabilités et s'est assis monsieur
jacob si vous voulez un vrai débat pour
les français si nous voulons sortir de
cette crise politique que traduit aussi
le nouveau lundi et l'abstention vous
vous devez vous découvrir présenter un
vrai projet aux français avec en ligne
de mire les élections régionales de
décembre prochain en cas de nouvelle
débâcle électorale pas sûr que manuel
valls pourrait fêter son deuxième
anniversaire à matignon manuel valls les
français me demande de rester dit il
est-ce que vous pensez que le premier
ministre a encore des soutiens ou c'est
plutôt un homme seul non mais je crois
pas que je crois que le premier ministre
a raison les français n'ont pas voté
pour dire tout d'un coup au
départemental il faut changer le premier
ministre le sujet n'est pas là le sujet
comme comme l'a dit manuel valls c'est
le contenu notre politique et surtout
les résultats que ce prix doit en
changer le cap j'ai cru sentir soit peu
la déception qui fait sentir quand même
cette semaine que il y avait une volonté
du gouvernement s'était fait d'ailleurs
avec l'annnonce du du séminaire
gouvernemental de mercredi prochain vous
voyez est de l incident oui s'ils voient
ce qu'ils voient un signe d' écoute des
des français un signe d' écoute aussi de
ce que peuvent dire certains au parti
socialiste entre autres par quelques
comme martine aubry comme comme bien
d'autres sur le fait que à l'intérieur
de de la politique économique du
gouvernement il faut peut-être
rééquilibrer vers plus être peut-être
plus volontariste sur la question qui
est une question majeure pour le pays à
savoir l'investissement
public l'investissement privé mais vous
savez comme agents d'entreprises
soutiennent bien les une bonne
entreprise pour pouvoir soutenir la
croissance on l'a un peu qui faisait
signe qu'elle
y à deux facteurs ont sont celles celle
à la baisse de l'euro et la baisse des
prix du pétrole donc ça c'est
conjoncturel oui c'est quand j'en parle
mais on voit tout d'un coup
qu'effectivement c'est c'est plutôt la
consommation actuellement qui soutient
l'économie qui soutient la croissance
mais ceci est arrivé à une croissance
qui va être trop faible bon donc ils
sont gratuits nuée par ce gouvernement
ceux-ci ce petit salé et appris à l'est
il ya des blessures il ya aussi des
réserves à décines capituler le
gouvernement et puis un soutien aux
entreprises le problème c'est que ce
soutien n'a pas été ciblés et pas été
suffisamment équilibré pour qu'il y ait
des contreparties en termes de création
d'emplois en termes de formation en
termes d'investissements et c'est ça
qu'on attend actuellement parce que la
croissance française qu'elle commence à
produire de l'emploi il faut être plus
haute bon et je prends un exemple la
question des collectivités locales on a
appris la semaine dernière que si le
déficit était réduit c'est parce qu'il y
avait eu 4 milliards 7
d'investissements en moins de la part
des collectivités locales sa touche
directement l'emploi de proximité
l'emploi des noms non délocalisables il
faut qu'on arrête il faut que si je suis
tout petit peu françois lamy vous dites
il ya eu un signe cette semaine envers
ceux qui prônent sable un changement ça
bouge un peu ligne voilà moi j'aime bien
maintenant on attend de voir quelles
vont être les propositions concrètes du
gouvernement mais c'est vrai que si le
gouvernement décide de rééquilibrer sa
politique économique pour la fléche est
beaucoup plus sur l'investissement
public l'investissement privé de façon à
aller chercher les points de croissance
alors ben on sera on sera plutôt deux
attendent et vous allez leur direction
ça veut dire quoi une meilleure
direction pour avoir des résultats parce
que c'est ça qu'une meilleure direction
pour soutenir le gouvernement parce que
jusque là martine aubry et vous et les
autres vous ne mangez pas forcément si
moi j'ai connu un moment j'ai voté le
budget voté le budget de la sécurité
sociale je vous dis pas vraiment j'étais
d'accord avec toulon faut tout
particulièrement sur la question des
collectivités moi ce que je pense
simplement c'est que dans la période
critique qui vient j'entendais ctos le
bartolone parler du rassemblement oui il
faut rassembler la gauche mais fall a
rassemblé autour d'un contenu il n'y a
pas de rassemblement son contenu les
électeurs écologistes une partie des
électeurs socialistes qui nous ont
quittés soit parce qu'ils se sont
réfugiés dans l'abstention soit dans un
vote vers un autre un autre parti ils
attendent de nous à ce que ne disent pas
simplement rassemblement rassemblement
mais qu'on donne un contenu il ya des
propositions qui sont sur la table des
uns et les autres et c'est ça qui fait
la richesse justement de la gauche c'est
qu'on profite de sa diversité et
peut-être qu'un peu plus d coûte à peu
près après cette défaite va permettre de
trouver les bonnes solutions justement
un peu plus d'écouter ce que vous avez
demandé lors d'un rassemblement avec vos
proches avec martine aubry on voit ça en
images son sujet en reportage et on
rediscute juste après pas de prise de
parole mais une présence à l'assemblée
nationale qui s'apparente à une
démonstration de force martine aubry a
réuni ses troupes hier la maire de lille
et ses soutiens demande qu'une
réorientation du pacte de responsabilité
nous voyons avec elle plutôt du côté
d'un soutien massif
à l'investissement privé et public c'est
à dire un autre usage de ce pacte de
responsabilité
cécile et est d'une efficacité massive
pour l'investissement pour l'emploi nous
aurions fait amende honorable ça n'est
pas le cas depuis le soir du second tour
martine aubry mène l'offensive contre
l'exécutif qu'elle accuse d'être
responsable de la défaite des élections
départementales
le président de la république pourrait
alors donner des gages à l'ancienne
première secrétaire du ps
redistribuer quelques milliards d'euros
du pacte de responsabilité vers
l'investissement public et privé mais au
gouvernement on refuse d'y voir une
réorientation l'action du gouvernement
sur ce sujet du pack de responsabilité
elle est très claire on remet pas en
cause les choix qui ont été faits de
soutenir l'industrie l'entreprise parce
que on a perdu beaucoup de parts de
marché et beaucoup de compétitivité on
va pas y revenir c'est un choix qui a
été fait réorientation
non après qu'on soit capable de regarder
et de mettre en place après ce qui s'est
passé et aussi parce qu'il ya besoin de
conforter la croissance des éléments
être à l'écouté est capable de cours
gestion de choses ça fait partie du
débat la majorité se montre fébrile à
deux mois du congrès du parti socialiste
martine aubry dépose rappelle une motion
contre jean christophe cambadélis
rassemblera tél au delà de son camp les
frondeurs par exemple elle réserve sa
réponse à mardi prochain le temps de
faire monter les enchères par françois
lamy jim jarrassé nous a rejoint du
figaro il va vous poser des questions
très personnelles dans un instant mais
moi je voudrais une question très
franche très clair et j'espère une
réponse aussi très clair est-ce que
martine aubry va déposer une motion au
congrès du parti social verra ça ça va
je suis très clair on saura ça la
semaine prochaine puisque c'est le 11 le
11 avril ont entendu que ce qu'on
appelle le besoin naturel de synthèse et
bien on attend contrairement d'ailleurs
à ce que dit le commentaire du reportage
on ne mène pas l'offensive contre
l'exécutif on mène l'offensive pour
aider l'exécutif parce qu'on souhaite
que la deuxième partie du quinquennat
réussisse
ça suppose qu effectivement on soit dans
l' écoute dans le dialogue
il ya eu des propositions qui ont été
mises sur la table vous savez que
martine aubry a rencontré avec jean marc
ayrault et le président de la république
elle a eu l'occasion d'avoir un petit
déjeuner à lille avec le premier
ministre a fait part de ses propositions
et donc la question de la motion ou pas
motion est une question qui n'intéresse
personne la question qui se pose c'est
de savoir où est ce qu'on va être le
plus utile pour pouvoir aider le
gouverneur c'est ce congrès doit servir
à ça un congrès vous savez pour que nos
téléspectateurs comprennent c'est pas
sérieux on a toujours l'impression d'une
grande messe avec des conflits pouvoir
honnêtement on s'en moque la question
des places à l'intérieur du parti
socialiste n'est pas là ce n'est pas le
sujet mais encore en capacité de faire
que ce congrès soit utile pour que le
quinquennat réussie vous n'avez pas aux
sommes le parti au pouvoir oui oui
fonctionne mais vous n'avez pas rejoint
la motion de benoît hamon qui appelait
le gauche du parti socialiste
vous vous attendez encore pour savoir si
vous allez rejoindre celle de
jean-christophe cambadélis qui plutôt
majoritaire vous êtes au milieu vous
voulez jouer l'arbitré ça nous sommes
rompus constaté peut-être que je fais
qui m'ont on est en position centrale
c'était un point d'équilibré entre la
gauche du parti et puis sont elles plus
entre guillemets droitière on est à la
fois n'ont fait pas monter les enchères
on est soucieux que la gauche réussisse
avec moi j'ai été aux côtés de martine
aubry son conseiller politique pendant
toutes les années d'opposition après le
comte fameux grand congrès de reims on a
remis on a regagné toutes les élections
j'ai coordonné des régionales et
départementales
on a travaillé pour que le projet
socialiste socialiste soit donnée
justement l unanimité on n'a pas fait
tout ça on a fait la primaire qui a bien
fonctionné et qui a permis le
rassemblement après on n'a pas fait tout
ça pour qu'elles arrivent et ceux qui
étaient là et soutenez bon et donc nos
ressources de la guerre dans la maison
pour l'instant mais celle là là nous on
jugera dans le courant de la semaine ou
est-ce qu'on ne sera le plus utile pour
continuer à aider à soutenir l'exécutif
ça suppose des fois de temps en temps 2
2 j'allais dire de montrer notre force
justement une motion c'est un moyen
aussi de défendre vos idées de continuer
à exister l'intérêt auriez-vous à
rejoindre la maison c'est un fait ça
c'est un texte qui est pris et qui a
rangé dans un tiroir comme cela arrive
souvent dans les textes du peuple du
parti socialiste ça nous intéresse pas
si en revanche leurs droits nous
positionnons 6,7 avec jean christophe
cambadélis ou avec d'autres plages où
dit on verra ça la semaine nous ce que
l'on souhaite surtout c'est qu'on soit
en capacité de voir avec l'exécutif
comment faire évoluer la politique on ne
demande pas le changement de la
politique au sens actuel tient tient
d'accord d'investissement à l'intérieur
des 40 milliards et vous le disais c'est
quand ça vous arrive est libre et on
souhaite qu un dialogue puisse
travailler d'une manière conforte sur
les inégalités territoriales contre ont
pesé sur les élections le départemental
on souhaite que la sont un certain
nombre de domaines des choses bougent
qu'elle serait écrit ou qu'elle se
réoriente et en salle et venteux l'a
bien compris vous y voyez des signes
depuis quelques jours ya un signe qui
veut faire vous donc la tendance serait
plutôt à un rapprochement est bien pour
l'instant la tendance est d'être regardé
ce qu'on va nous proposer voilà et puis
on prendra la décision au monde et
dernière question toutes les options
sont sur la table voilà un indice est
ouvert à la décision on prendra la
décision il paraît en la semaine
prochaine que martine aubry doit
rencontrer à nouveau françois hollande
oui non moi je vous savez je ne dis
jamais ça je ne sais jamais quand il y à
des rencontres sera je ne dis jamais le
contenu des rencontres parce que je
crois en politique comme je dis souvent
que quand on fait un peu de diplomatie
politique il faut toujours rester et
vous seriez vous n'excluez pas donc on
n'en sait rien alors c'est l'heure
d'accueillir françois la vie notre
partenaire du figaro pour un décryptage
de l'actualité politique c'est la loupe
du scan
j'aimais j'arrache bonjour
on va reparler de martine aubry tout à
fait on a on a beaucoup parlé de martine
aubry décidément elle vous a confié il
ya quelques jours une mission sur la
politique de la ville à lille vous voilà
installé pour de bon dans le département
du nord quelles sont vos ambitions dans
ce département est ce que vous visez les
régionales les prochaines législatives
est ce que voilà vous avez déjà une idée
en tête et c'est une vision de la
politique qui n'est pas la mienne qui
consiste à croire que dès qu'on fait
quelque chose on a toujours toujours
toujours un objectif en terme de mandats
de conques et c'est pas voter c'est pas
ça n'a jamais été mon cas j'ai jamais
bâti ma vie politique en établissant un
plan de carrière ne vais pas commencer à
55 ans j'ai fait un choix qui était dire
que sur le territoire dans lequel
j'évolue et politiquement dans lequel je
vivais à savoir l'essonne j'avais je
crois a rempli ma mission et qu'il
fallait passer à passer à autre chose ça
m'a proposé de venir à lille bon j'y vis
j'y me dit
et puis après on dira quoi leur revanche
ce qui m'intéresse ce qui m'intéresse
vraiment c'est que dans les missions
qu'elle m'a confié qu'il dépasse
d'ailleurs la politique de la ville sur
la question du vivre ensemble ces deux
d'essayer de comprendre pourquoi dans
une ville qui est une ville très riche
très populaire très riche c'est le dire
n'ont pas financièrement parce que c'est
une ville pauvre mais riche en terme de
relations humaines dans une ville
populaire pourquoi est-ce que même quand
on a dans un quartier mener une action
assez assez forte pour quoi il ya certes
un déclic certains ressorts qui ne
fonctionne pas alors que ça ça
m'intéresse de regarder pont justement
vous parliez de l'esadse la
circonscription dans laquelle vous avez
été élu est ce que vous vous y rendez
encore sur fréquemment donc vous
électeurs ont pris le fait que vous
partiez à lille vous savez ce que ceux
qui m'aiment bien ont compris ouais tout
voilà on ne filme pas créer à la
désertion crie à la diversion alors que
paris n'avait pas envie que je reste à
jamais su le fait de démissionner de
votre mandat dans l'essonne si vous
partez oui j'ai fait j'ai effectué c'est
un peu compliqué en termes d'emploi du
temps mais ça c'est plutôt mon problème
est sûre je continue vous savez la spla
nice je suis sur le territoire où entre
autres à une partie du plateau de saclay
donc à nos yeux assez important en
matière de recherche et d'innovation la
semaine dernière j'étais en train de
travailler avec les directeur général de
polytechnique avec son équipe voilà je
m'organise j'ai toujours une cellule
locale voilà j'essaie d'aider au mieux
alors voilà toujours sur l'essonne votre
suppléant à l'assemblée jérôme guedj a
été battu dimanche au second tour pour
les départementales alors certains au ps
comme julien dray il s'est exprimé
publiquement excusé aussi et manuel
valls dit on lui reproche d'avoir
préféré faire campagne à la télévision
pour dénoncer la politique du
gouvernement plutôt que d'aller sur le
terrain au contact de ses électeurs est
ce que cette critique est justifiée
selon elle et elle n'est pas justifiée
d'ailleurs julien dray je crois s'est
excusé
au contraire jérôme a mené un
fantastique bateau fantastique bataille
de terrain mais pas uniquement pendant
la campagne depuis qu'il est élu
président du conseil général c'est la
poule g de cette élection c'est que on
n'a pas assez parlé des compétences du
conseil général de ce qui a pu faire ça
les à côtés dans ma circonscription de
bourgis où on a inauguré ensemble il ya
deux ans une maison de retraite année
magnifique établissement et 60 euros par
jour voilà s'il permet du coup un accès
pour une ville comme ça donc donc voilà
je crois qu'ils ont fait le maximum mais
qui avait un certain nombre de facteurs
extérieurs qui ne permettait pas le
garder le crous lauragais je remarquais
que dans son canton il a été élu et que
ce canton est dense et 59 sa future sa
conception peut-être oui peut-être mais
peut-être qu'il sera candidat oui
d'accord alors ce mardi on l'a dit tout
à l'heure c'était les un nom de manuel
valls à matignon j'ai une petite
question quel cadeau auriez vous aimé
lui offrir à cette occasion je vais vous
en proposer 4 alors la première une
prothèse auditive pour qu'ils entendent
mieux les rendent les revendications à
sa gauche un livre de kells on parle
d'investissements justement de théorie
économique sur l'investissement un
billet d'avion pour qu'il s'en aille
loin en vacances ou alors une balle anti
stress
non je prendrai le billet d'avion mais
pas pour qu'il aille en vacances c'est
parce que ça fait référence à ce qui a
circulé lorsque louis jeunesse et quitte
le gouvernement il m'avait conseillé de
prendre de longues vacances je lui
enverrai plutôt un billet d'avion que
j'aurais moi-même utilisé pour lui
montrer que j'avais suivi ses conseils
et je suis revenu en pleine forme vous
vous lavez mal pris cette réflexion ne
manuel va jamais c'est jamais très
facile de cliquer gouvernement surtout
quand on est engagé dans une action
aussi passionnante que celle que j'avais
sur sur des quartiers quartier craplet
afin de revenir mais vous savez oui
c'est vrai qu'on m'a proposé le revenu
avec +0 physique parce que n'étaient pas
cohérents politiquement mais si on vous
en boucher un degré jamais je n'ai
aucune animosité envers manuel valls que
je connais depuis très très longtemps
cela bien sûr travailler ensemble ya 30
ans à lyon 2 propose de revenir à
nouveau mais la question se pose pas
comme ça c'est toujours le contenu
politique qui doit qui doit guider
l'action au mois deux offert août j'ai
estimé que je serais plus utile à
l'extérieur qu'à l'intérieur du
gouvernement voilà donc si jamais on a
dans des semaines qui viennent des
choses qui bougent si ça se rééquilibre
dans ce sens que nous souhaitons ici
c'est utile que le président de la
république juste de ré élargir et je
pense que ce serait utile sa majorité
son gouvernement tout parler à toutes
les sensibilités du parti socialiste aux
écologistes et ainsi de suite chacun
prendra ses responsabilités c'est rien
c'est toujours eu pour habitude de le
fermer le sujet c'est c'est un point
d'aboutissement
voilà l'importance et la réussite du
quinquennat c'est le fait que ces deux
ans soit soit elles soient utiles après
le reste nouvelle importance points
merci on se revoit la semaine prochaine
bien entendu de senna on va retourner au
sénat cette fois ou qui a ouvert le
débat sur la lutte contre la
prostitution le texte voté en 2013 à
l'assemblée nationale a été profondément
modifiées aussi avec sa verrière ogec
inacceptable scandaleux les mots sont
violents après le vote par le sénat du
texte sur la prostitution cas les
sénateurs ont complètement modifier
l'esprit de la loi ils ont supprimé la
pénalisation du client rétabli le délit
de racolage la mesure la plus efficace
pour lutter contre les réseaux selon le
président de la commission spéciale nous
déposons ce le rétablissement du délit
de racolage parce que sans ce
rétablissement madame la ministre je
vous le dis très sincèrement nous
serions sur un texte qui se trouverait
en état d'apesanteur pour la gauche au
contraire établir le délit de racolage
revient à criminaliser les prostituées
quant à la pénalisation du client
l'objectif de la mesure était de montrer
que c'est bien ce client qui crée la
prostitution comme explique laurence
cohen ne pas mettre la pénalisation des
clients c'est toléré ces violences
sexuelles est toléré le fait qu'on fasse
du corps une marchandise un commerce et
refusé de faire entrer effectivement les
clients dans le système prostitutionnel
c'est réfuté toute la réalité de la
prostitution
pour marisol touraine le sénat a fait
des prostituées non pas des victimes
mais des coupables la ministre des
affaires sociales qui parle de mépris à
l'égard des femmes la pénalisation des
clients sera réintroduite lors du retour
du texte à l'assemblée le parti
socialiste a dit que c'était un texte
régressif et il montre la déconnexion
cela avec les enjeux de la société oui
mais je pense que effectivement le sénat
compte les rats est revenu à ses
positions très conservatrices
sur la question de la prostitution
considérons filaments qui avait pas de
responsabilité du client et que c'était
finalement la prostituée qui était
responsable de son état de fait après
moi je pense que sur ce dossier là
il faut qu'on aille plus loin dans un
sur un domaine dont on parle pas assez
puis surtout la paix réalisation des
réseaux voilà de ceux qui exploitent ces
femmes à des fins financières et quand
il exploite de manière une fois encore
totalement inhumaine quoi bon je crois
que c'est peut-être là dessus qu'il
faudrait dans l'est dans les mois qui
viennent maintenant que comporte notre
action c'est ça qui serait le plus
efficace parce que une loi qui ferait
que finalement on rend plus où on cache
les prostituées pour que ça ne se voit
pas ne serait pas une loi efficace
mercredi le premier ministre interpellé
à l'assemblée sur la question de la
suspension d'un directeur d'école écroué
pour viol sur élèves
une députée ump a mis en cause la
politique pénale et le laxisme du
gouvernement dans cette affaire selon
elle très en colère le premier ministre
lui a répondu écoutez cet échange
mercredi dans l'hémicycle nous sommes
inquiet car le laxisme de votre
politique pénale depuis trois ans n'est
pas compatible
ah ouais avec la fermeté qui doit en
l'espèce appliquée depuis que ces
histoires ai connu d'autres cas semble
apparaître ce qui laisse penser que la
non transmission par la justice des
condamnés sur l'éducation nationale est
chose fréquente la sphère de
villefontaine a commencé en 2008 en 2008
madame la députée najat vallaud belkacem
le rappelait tout à l'heure plutôt que
de chercher une nouvelle fois comme vous
l'avez fait pendant toute la campagne à
chercher la polémique avec le
gouvernement
la polémique avec la majorité la
polémique avec la garde des sceaux pour
la salir comme certains ont voulu salir
madame najat vallaud-belkacem alors
assez ça suffit de à chaque fois sur ces
sujets là sur la sécurité
c est moi je me dis je redis à la
majorité madame la députée je le vis à
toute la majorité il ne faut plus se
laisser faire par les attaques par la
démagogie par l'outrance qui a été en
permanence la vôtre je n'accepterai plus
madame la députée que vous nous traîniez
à chaque fois dans la boue françois lamy
vous étiez dans les visites la seconde
tumulte qu'est-ce qu'il a eu raison de
réagir que bien sûr il a eu raison de
réagir c'est ce qu'on a le 2-2 de se
servir de
ce qui s'est passé de cet acte enfin de
cette situation on retrouve
un instituteur un directeur d'école qui
commettaient des actes pédophiles voilà
et de s'en servir à des fins politiques
croient que on peut pas faire ça on peut
pas tout faire en politique et en
l'occurrence que christiane taubira
n'est pour rien dans ce qui s'est passé
à villefontaine comme najat vallaud
belkacem c'est pas
le fruit d'une politique c'est
effectivement peut-être que dira qu'il
ya eu des choses peut-être à renforcer
l'objet de l'anc est entre les deux
inspections générales du ministère
l'éducation nationale et du ministère de
la justice pour essayer de comprendre
pourquoi systématiquement la justice ne
transmet pas ces dossiers là l'éducation
nationale en forme de stigmatisation de
ces deux ministres soient khristenko il
ya une volonté de la droite qui est qui
est très claire de vouloir à chaque fois
frappé à travers ces deux personnes des
politiques qui sont qui sont menés bon
mais on va pas faire croire que c'est la
politique de 2,2 de christiane taubira
qui qui a fait que tout d'un coup le ce
qui s'est passé à villefontaine a été
rendue possible possible c'est faut donc
il est vrai que manuel valls a raison
une fois il faut que ça s'arrête il faut
que ça cesse 0 on peut pas comme je vous
le disais tout se permettaient politique
il a créé j'ai beaucoup de colère qu'ils
aient eu raison il a eu raison et parce
que nous étions tous en colère à ce
moment-là erreurs moi j'ai le souvenir
est souvent malheureusement le cas à
droite le fait qu'on se serve d'un crime
d'un fait divers des foi au dieu pour
tout d'un coup on rendre responsables
les responsables politiques le
gouvernement en place l'exécutif c'est
intolérable
alors toujours à l'assemblée françois
lamy il ya eu cet amendement socialiste
voté dans le cadre de la loi santé il
interdit l'emploi des mannequins
anorexiques
c'est une bonne chose comme oui tout à
fait comme chez toi est une excellente
voie de gauche voilà moi je souhaite que
mes oui parce qu'on ne dit pas c'est
donc on
fabrique des électeurs ont pas
l'impression de que que l'on mène la
bonne politique donc à chaque fois qu'on
al'occasion pouvoir lire oui c'est une
vraie loi de gauche divise a senti n'est
pas uniquement guidés par des soucis
financiers de valeur
il ya effectivement ce souci-là de la
part de marisol touraine
il ya une volonté de changer les choses
pour la santé des français de faire que
ça a ému et de faire plus de justice
c'est le cas avec le tiers payant entre
autres sur le fait qu'on ne soit plus
obligé de faire la vence à son médecin
de des frais de soins donc c'est une
vraie loi de gauche qu'il faut soutenir
oui c'est vrai qu'il ya déjà des
rapprochements cette semaine avant son
heureux non mais je peux avoir la corde
à vent ou s'il va pas changer enfin si
om là non pas ce jeudi on va parler du
troisième tour des élections
départementales on évitait nous avons le
président des conseils départementaux
et on vous propose donc le bilan de ce
troisième tour petit tour de france de
ces élections départementales troisième
tour avec sandra cerqueira
c'est la surprise de ce troisième tour
des départementales la chute du
président du conseil général depuis 30
ans on sait clairement la victoire de
l'ump qui avait perdu dans les urnes
jean michel baylet comprend au dernier
moment qu'il n'aura pas de majorité et
décide de laisser sa place à la maire
prg marie claude elle sera battue
par christian astruc divers gauche
soutenu par la droite 18 voix contre 12
dans les bouches du rhône jean noël
guérini qui n'avait aucune chance de
l'emporter décide de jeter l'épongé sans
surprise c'est la droite arrivée
majoritaire qui prend pour la première
fois la présidence du département l'ump
martine vassal est élu dès le premier
tour je crois que c'est important c'est
que la machine continue
et ensuite après par la suite nous
appliquerons
le programme pour lequel nous avons été
élus il aura fallu un troisième tour
dans l'aisne pour choisir le nouveau
président et l'élection n'a pas été
simple c'est grâce à un accord ump udi
que nicolas fricoteaux a été élu à la
majorité relative mais sans réelle
majorité la droite n'a pas les mains
libres pour faire adopter les budgets la
gestion du département s'annonce
difficile je chercherai des partenaires
pour voter avec bon sens dans le
vaucluse jusqu'au bout du scrutin le fn
a présenté un candidat avec le soutien
des élus extrême droite de la ligue du
sud mais l'élection très serré s'est
jouée entre la droite et la gauche
restant à égalité l'ump l'emporté
finalement face au ps grâce à la règle
du bénéfice de l'âge maurice chabert 71
ans est le nouveau président du vaucluse
en corrèze le chiraquien pascal costes
est élu au premier tour face au
socialiste gérard bonnet une prouesse
dans le fief de françois hollande enfin
en lozère c'est bien la socialiste
sophie pantel qui est élu dès le premier
tour seul département a basculé à gauche
jean michel baylet et conduit c'est la
fin d'une époque oui oui c'est la fin
d'une époque ça faisait 45 ans je crois
voilà donc
je crois que dans département du tarn et
garonne et demi page est en train de se
tourner voilà une histoire très longue
très compliqué très radicale de rejet
est en train de plancher racines très
très très très profondément dont deux en
tarn et garonne est une terre radicale
voilà c'est fini c'est que jean matthieu
ballet est à la fois le patron du prg
mais aussi la dépêche ce bon voilà c'est
la fin d'une épopée et après ça et ça et
ça fait deux parties non je ne crois pas
parce que mon père j'ai
souvent perdu département du tarn et
garonne suspense en tout cas je l'espère
bon mais c'est vrai qu'on a à l'occasion
de ce troisième tour des des endroits où
effectivement soit on met fin à une
époque soit on fait sa faim système les
nouvelles générations aussi un bouches
du rhône oui là où les élus sont là
depuis trop longtemps vous savez
d'ailleurs c'est une c était un des
éléments de ma réflexion pour le bon
départ de l'essonne sagesse alger 30 ans
voilà fallait pas faire le mandat de
trop une réaction peut-être sur les mots
prononcés cette semaine par jean-marie
le pen qui persiste et signe sur
chambres à gaz détail de l'histoire un
commentaire ça sera jugé j'espère
sévèrement par la justice voilà et puis
appuie une fois de plus je crois que
c'est le mode est trop pour le problème
est ce que ça aura des 106 cm mais c'est
à dire que le problème c'est qu'on va
constater qu'il ya pas de conséquence à
l'intérieur des structures du fn s'était
déjà que monsieur le pen va rester le
président d'honneur bon j'ai ça qu'elle
ira pour conduire la vue ou jamais l'on
savait ce qu'il pensait lui on sait
qu'il a été plusieurs fois plusieurs
fois condamné pour le pur racisme ou et
une fois pour pour tout antisémitisme
donc voilà on connaissait le personnage
mais c'est quand même c'est que ça ne se
traduit jamais dans l'organisation du
front national est qu en fait derrière
le phare derrière les masques c'est
toujours les mêmes d'ailleurs il l'a
très bien dit comme si vu son interview
médical et gaullistes j'en ai pas vu
beaucoup les caves et les anciens
pétainiste là effectivement c'était le
coeur du système quoi disqualifiées pour
conduire la liste en région paca pour
les régionales et bien si enfin c'est
pour à moi de juger ce que fera de ce
que le front national en tout cas moi ce
qui m'importe c'est qu'on soit en
capacité de rassembler la gauche pour
pouvoir empêcher que le front national
puisse conquérir la région paca bien sûr
on va passer sur un tout autre sujet ça
s'appelle le plus de l'hebdo et on lui
consacre sa semaine à la radio et à la
télévision publique
plus de quinze jours de grève pour radio
france qui se cherche aussi un nouveau
pas trop du côté de france télévisions
le service public en france est il
malade aura posé la question et les
bonnes réponses avec simon barbarie plus
de quinze jours de grève à radio france
du jamais vu depuis vingt ans et comme
une prise de conscience pour ses
auditeurs d'un audiovisuel public en
pleine crise 21 millions euros de pertes
pour la maison ronde cette année la
prévision d'un plan social de plusieurs
centaines de salariés et une crise qui
tourne à l'affrontement politique l'ump
et nicolas sarkozy y voit un scandale
d'état et pointe du doigt la gestion de
l'audiovisuel public sous françois
hollande vous ne tenez pas les
engagements budgétaires de l'état envers
radio france ce sont plus de 87 millions
d'euros qui manquent sur la période
2012-2014 c'est votre gouvernement qui
est responsable de la crise actuelle de
radio france c'est radio france est en
pleine tourmente france télévisions elle
n'en est pas loin un plan de départs
volontaires doit prochainement toucher
400 postes des audiences à la baisse
près de 10 millions d'euros de déficit
cette année et la désignation de son
président qui fait débat le mois
prochain le csa nommera le futur pdg de
france télés une procédure opaque pour
l'ump l'opposition a la mémoire courte
pour le gouvernement parce qu'il faut
quand même se rappeler comment ça se
passe et de votre temps les nominations
et la vie c'était simple comme un coup
de fil du président là il vous plaît
monsieur meunier
et la modernité la transparence là
dedans pouvez vous me le dire des
affrontements partisans qui ne doivent
pas faire oublier les véritables enjeux
de cette crise le modèle économique et
les valeurs de l'audiovisuel public à
redéfinir d'urgence au sujet de radio
france la cour des comptes est sévère
elle pointe des défaillances qui ne sont
pas acceptables et des coûts qui sont en
augmentation puisque l'état a sa part de
responsabilité dans cette situation
c'est pour vous dire la vérité ça
dossier que je ne connais que j'ai pas
eu l'occasion de lire le rapport de deux
heures face à moi ce qui me semble voilà
ce qui me semble très important
effectivement mais c'est à la fois je
vais dire en tant qu'usagers puisque moi
je suis un fidèle auditeur aux
téléspectateurs du service public je
pense aussi aux salariés parce que on
voit des des salariés qui sont vraiment
c'est à dire il motivé c'est même pas le
mot fin qui sont pleinement à
l'intérieur passionné par par par leur
métier bon et donc je pense qu'il faut
que les discussions des négociations
aboutissent mois après c'est vrai que
s'il ya eu des erreurs de gestion
il faut qu'on les corrige il faut qu'on
se pose la question aussi de futurs de
la rationalisation peut-être de
certaines des missions entre fonce à
france inter france info peut-être que
en gardant la spécificité des deux des
deux stations soient en capacité
peut-être de mutualiser aussi bon qu'un
certain nombre de choses à faire pour
être aussi performant aussi bon que
l'est le service public il faudrait
aussi
après tous ces rapports qu'on a entendu
cinq cents ans de gabegie financière
encore une fois oui je me méfie parce
que je
les rapports de la cour des comptes
traduisent des fois du des réalités bon
et puis des fois traduisent aussi des
options qui sont un peu plus politique
un mot peut-être dans quelques seconds
plage fait je fais attention moi j'ai
pris confiance en lui comme moi
professionnellement sur cet homme
mathieu gallet qui imprime qu'émissaire
en ce moment de donc avec de toutes
parts est-ce qu'il s'est trompé dans sa
gestion visiblement enfin quand un
compteur on est happé léger leur allure
de radio france et qu'on se retrouve
avec oyonnax lyon n'est pas
7 jours 17 jours de grève c'est qu'il ya
peut-être un petit problème quand en
tout cas dans la discussion avec avec
ses salariés je dire bon après il ya ça
tombe d'erreurs qui sont qui sont
montrés du doigt de rénovation de
bureaux je pense qu'il faut que les tout
comme les responsables politiques
d'ailleurs un certain nombre de deux
responsables
d'entités comme celle de radio france
comprenne que le monde a changé voilà et
que les gens sont peu plus en plus prêts
à accepter n'importe quoi ce qui était
possible valable l'avatange nous du plus
bas taux est bien le monde a changé ce
sera donc les paroles de la fin merci
sur la fin de cette émission merci
françois la vie prochain